[Music]
the future of cars is electric it may
not seem that way yet electric vehicles
are still a relatively niche product
with a small buyer base but global
automakers are betting big on TVs and
investing billions to wean themselves
off of the gasoline engine dozens of new
plug-in models are expected to arrive at
dealerships around the world in the next
few years The Wall Street Journal set
out to better understand what it's like
to live with an electric car today with
a globe spanning experiment four
countries eight different reporters
eight different vehicles we tasked
reporters to each spend three weeks
driving an electric vehicle to see how
they fit into their everyday lives
Lulu Houston we wanted to find out what
compromises do drivers have to make to
own 180 degrees outside we can't read
our charging stations available and do
they work I've come to a rural part of
Shanghai and we even out here found
electricity that we can charge the car
up what's it like to take an Eevee on a
road trip fast charging station and
world's tallest thermometer four percent
battery left I mean it to the wrist area
a little nerve-wracking but here we are
we've been sitting in this parking lot
charging for three and a half hours and
most importantly can they be your main
vehicle we are going to take this up on
the Autobahn so if you see this video we
did not die
all the cars we tested were pure
electrics
meaning they only run on battery power
no gasoline but this isn't a typical car
review we're testing the experience to
see if the world is really ready to make
the switch to electric vehicles go today
is road trip day so this is going to be
an interesting experience let's roll
let's roll the future is now zones
[Music]
I'm Nora Anton I'm a reporter at The
Wall Street Journal I cover the
automotive industry here in Detroit
since we're really expanding the globe
here with eight reporters and eight
cities that means we're going to get
some pretty diverse experiences I mean
some of these reporters live in
single-family homes some of them live in
apartments there are big cities there
are more rural areas everyone is keeping
a daily log of how many miles they're
driving how many hours they're charging
what kind of Chargers they're using even
if they get stuck there keeping track of
that all the cars for this test were
lent to us by the manufacturers we've
got a brand new car get 74 kilometers on
it except for the Tesla Model 3 which we
rented with the turo app along the way
we're speaking with auto industry
experts and drivers for their insights
on electric vehicles
hi Valerie how do you think it's gonna
go in Raleigh
you know I'm fascinated to find out I
think it's gonna be possible to drive
and charge in the city limits but North
Carolina is a pretty rural state and
South is a really spread out so my
question is what's gonna happen when you
get outside of a city how do you think
that's gonna go in Houston it's a pretty
big oil town right it's a big town but
these have been increasing market share
here so they'll be interesting to see
how the charging network is built out
what car you gonna drive yeah plus the
one that's got the bigger battery I
guess I guess I was worrying about me
getting stranded or something do
something you don't get to do very often
in Tokyo because you don't own a car
we're going to Costco to see Detroit
this like really old-school
manufacturing town be part of this shift
to electric vehicles has been really
interesting to watch General Motors
makes the Chevy bolt I'm driving for
this test the Detroit auto giant is
restructuring its business to invest in
an electric future and has 20 new
battery power models debuting globally
GM isn't alone Ford Volkswagen Mercedes
BMW Hyundai and many others all have
plans to bring new plug-in vehicles to
market to some extent they have little
choice tougher auto emissions
regulations around the world are pushing
them in this direction the auto industry
is expected to spend about 225 billion
dollars on electrification globally over
the next few years but analysts aren't
convinced the big bet will pay off
electric cars accounted for just under
3% of global sales last year why is the
industry turning to this so hard now
what has changed in the last few years
there are several real driving factors
most notable is public opinion public
awareness of climate change
second factor is there's legislation
around the world supporting the move
encouraging automakers to get there it's
going to become more and more difficult
for any auto manufacturer in most
nations of the country to compete only
by providing internal combustion engines
the third piece is is there's some
economics behind it in the long run
electric vehicles are going to be
cheaper for people to own and operate
but the cars aren't exactly flying off
the lot today expensive batteries make
Eevee's a pricey option most cost ten to
twenty thousand dollars more than
similar sized gasoline cars Lee Hawkins
met Vince XI he who runs nearly 30
dealerships in the Washington DC area
how is the electric car market going
right now how are they selling here for
you electric vehicles are really just
getting off the ground there's still a
very small segment of the overall market
so how often do you have scenarios where
people are not necessarily coming in to
look at an electric vehicle and then
they say oh wow well maybe I'll try one
of these it's that very common that is
very uncommon it is very difficult to
make that educational leap with a
customer that's not prepared to talk
about an electric vehicle does that make
economic sense right now to buy an
electric car yeah it's an interesting
math equation to see what you have to
spend on electric versus what you're
getting from your local government there
are certain states that are fully behind
electric and that brings the cost down
to a very reasonable level I would say
the majority of the country it's still
more expensive even with the federal
subsidies that are out there and there's
no guarantee that they will last
across eight cities despite the
different cars and life routines we all
shared many common experiences
throughout the tests the cars took some
getting used to it first we'll see if we
can figure this out this is our first
public charging station looks like you
just stick it in there when you're
pressing on the accelerator when you
ease off the car automatically begins to
break and that's to preserve the battery
but once mastered we found the cars
precip II zippy has a lot of zip to it
those of us with the ability to charge
the cars at home had a much easier
experience charging for the first night
whether or not that's an option largely
depends on your housing and where you
park your car overnight it's more
feasible if you have your own garage or
driveway my colleagues using standard
home outlets could typically generate
enough charge overnight to carry them
through the next day is there any
greater feeling than a hundred percent
charge but for faster charging many evey
owners actually install a charger at
home on a higher voltage outlet I added
one at my house and it cost about seven
hundred dollars for the equipment at
about eight hundred dollars for the
electrical work the average cost in the
US for installing a home charger is
about fourteen hundred dollars those of
us living in apartment buildings instead
relied on public chargers they generally
found enough to get them around town but
it could be a hassle at times there are
no Chargers in my street
there are several Chargers about six
that I found so far in my neighborhood
directly about four five minute walk
from my house last night I wanted to
charge the car but all the charges were
false O'Neill addend of so we're now on
half a charge and keeping our fingers
crossed that it's enough to get us
through the day for Aaron's commutes and
other short trips the cars performed
well they had a range that's typical for
many new electric vehicles over two
hundred miles and that was more than
enough for getting reporters around town
after one week 391 kilometres of
capacity to go I'm about to charge the
leaf for the first time in
eight or nine days I wanted to do an
experiment to see how long I could go
without charging it if I were to just
run my normal errands and do my normal
commute but problems arose when we took
the cars on longer trips outside of city
centers we are driving from LA to Las
Vegas there's some really good fishing
for big Pike in nearly all the road
trips regardless of the city or country
the drives took significantly longer
than expected
despite meticulous planning on Halloween
Valerie drove two hours from Raleigh to
Wilmington North Carolina she ended up
getting stuck after driving around for
hours looking for a working charger it's
kind of a hot mess right now driving
around Wilmington North Carolina it took
her about eight hours to make it back
home which made her miss
trick-or-treating with her kids
the electric car vehicle in a small town
is the Grinch that stole Halloween we
asked Jaguar about Valerie's road trip
they said grouse in the evie market over
time will lead to better charging
infrastructure especially for longer
journeys Jaguar also said most of their
current evie drivers have a gasoline
vehicle as well
my planned road trip didn't go any
better I have made this list of charging
stations that we can stop at on the way
I drove from Plymouth Michigan to
Sleeping Bear Dunes which for me is
normally a 10-hour round-trip drive in a
gasoline vehicle but the cold weather
kept draining my battery and made it
slow to recharge if you look at the
outside temperature which is 25 degrees
right up there is dinging us by 34 miles
of range we have turned off the heat
several times to save on battery and
we're just freezing our butts off so
that we can make it to our destination I
ended up spending 30 hours on the road
19 of those charging we spent six hours
under charge
the amount of time it should have taken
us a try gas car so we are worn out I
asked Jim about my nightmare of a road
trip I spent 30 hours on the road back
and forth you know that's not super
feasible for people who aren't just
doing this for a test so it is this
really a car that you can take out on
the road at this point you can but you
you're a fine example I'm not gonna try
and sugarcoat it there are definitely a
number of pockets of the country that
are much tougher for you to find easy
charging and fast charging the speed of
the charge has to increase and the
number of available chargers definitely
also increase no doubt about it another
aspect of bringing these vehicles into
your everyday life especially here in
Michigan is that it gets cold for a good
amount of the year that really affects
the battery so is there a solution for
that on the horizon it's a normal
trade-off there's not a lot we can do
about that in the short term in a longer
term as batteries get more and more
efficient and we get more and more
natural range in the car you'll care
less and less that in the extreme
temperatures hot and cold that use a
little bit of range for many of us the
road trips made one thing clear range
anxiety is real and it can be quite
traumatic there was a moment where the
miles were just being eaten away I do
not want to get stranded that's a big
no-no sort of like Waterworld or Mad Max
when you're out on the highway I find
myself thinking well we're not gonna get
fuel how am I gonna get there quiet
silent terror when you're not really
sure whether or not we're gonna make it
back we often found ourselves driving
slower on the highway and foregoing
features on the car to conserve battery
the downside is that you don't can enjoy
all the cool things
Jack making the jack like that checkered
flag mode can't use that because it uses
too much energy top right corner there
that is the range of the battery and
then watch what happens as I turn the
air-conditioning fan up with so many
factors affecting the battery it was
hard to pin down the cars real range the
range estimate was kind of off you know
we did about 80 kilometers but lost
about 150 kilometers with a range
I guess maybe those highway speeds the
range is going down more quickly than we
anticipated and we don't know if we're
gonna make it to the charger that we
were planning to try to at Hyundai
Mercedes Jaguar and Nissan each said
their vehicles served the day-to-day
needs of a variety of drivers the
automakers told us that road conditions
driving styles and certain features
affect the range of both gasoline and
electric vehicles and each manufacturer
pointed to technology on their cars
designed to help evey drivers avoid
getting stuck such as route planning
tools real-time updates on range and
assistance finding chargers a lot of us
also experienced frustrating
deficiencies in the public charging
Network and not just in places like
northern Michigan and rural North
Carolina even in global auto capitals
like Japan and Germany where car
companies are stepping up investment in
EVs
our reporters found the charging
infrastructure lacking while in China
James arity found the most abundant and
easiest public charging in our test
these charging stations seem to be all
over in the city in Shanghai and it's
from what I can tell from the map
they're all over the country everywhere
else available public stations were a
hodgepodge charging at a new spot often
meant having to figure out a new
registration or interface thing can't be
used even though it's free can't be used
without a 9-step registration process in
which I have to wait for an email to
arrive in my mailbox
we often encountered machines that were
broken slower than expected or simply
occupied one charging station at the
hotel nobodies parked an Eevee in the
Eevee spots okay
a disaster area now cuz look it's
blinking red why we don't know it's
charging no it's not no matter how fast
the station charging these vehicles adds
a lot of time to a trip compared to
refueling a gasoline vehicle these
Chargers are effective but pretty slow
so we have some time to kill half an
hour while I'm waiting for my charging
full of noodles we've been sitting here
for an hour and 12 minutes there are
plenty of free charging stations but
when we did have to pay it was sometimes
surprisingly expensive some stations set
the rate based on time spent charging
others by kilowatt hour and the price of
electricity varies across the u.s. it
ended up costing a little over thirty
five dollars so if I was doing this once
a week I'd probably be more than I
currently spend on gas we're our
reporters encountered a patchwork of
charging infrastructure experts told us
it's largely because there isn't one
single entity responsible for building
it out rather in the US it's a mixture
of private landowners nonprofits and
companies like charge point and
Electrify America trying out different
business models Tesla was an outlier in
our test in 2012 the electric carmaker
began building out its own network of
fast charging stations so Tesla drivers
don't have to rely on public charging
Tesla says it now has more than 1,800
supercharger stations worldwide and
nearly 750 in the US li easily found
places to plug in his Tesla Model 3
whether it was during longer road trips
or routine errands there's just tons of
options all of these little lightning
bolts are super charging stations some
of us were jealous of Tesla's charging
infrastructure and takeaway for today is
if you're in Wilmington
and you have a Tesla you're probably
sent so many open spaces at the Tesla
there's approximately 14 Tesla stations
near us two non Tesla stations and one
of them is broken but Lee did encounter
lines at a station on the drive between
New York and DC as you can see they
can't get in because all of the charging
stations are already full and a fast and
abundant network doesn't remove the need
to plan for charging time the major
challenge of the trip was just the hour
that we had to spend charging that's
just part of the game like when you
decide that you're gonna purchase an
electric car you have to build that into
your expectations Tesla did not respond
to our requests for comment buying an
electric car right now means changing
some habits and accepting some
trade-offs while visiting charging
stations around Los Angeles
Eric Schwartzel met Evie owners who have
embraced these cars and all that comes
with them hey thanks have a good one
thanks for all your help everyone in
this world is so nice the woman we met
this morning Kathy was telling me that
she liked games it for herself and
she'll try to get to Vegas and back on
one charge it's like this real daredevil
move to try and make it like her range
is like 250 so she'll make a 270 mile
trip with like no a/c hey how are you
it's a good car
no man has never been to the shop just
replaced the tires and ever replace the
brakes it has a hundred thousand miles
on it
I bought this used for about four
thousand dollars and it's been the best
investment that I bought but Eric also
met drivers who had struggled with the
switch to an electric car well I only
had it for like eight months I've always
wanted one since
came out and I'm finally able to get one
but they just didn't work out for me why
is that because the charging stations in
Los Angeles are few and far between
where Chargers are lacking nonprofits
have stepped in to try and fill some of
the holes Kitty Adams runs one of them
Eric met her at a free charging station
she helped install at the LA Zoo where
is there still a dearth of charging
infrastructure in the United States when
the initial investment was going into
evey charging I saw them like really
getting crowded in commercial zones
which is great but you know rarely do I
ever need that charger at the drugstore
by my house where I really need it is
when I'm driving you know 40 miles to
leo carrillo state beach more
unconventional locations yes so it's
really important to have that e V
charger there because otherwise people
can't take that trip but having said
that you can't make a case for
commercializing that charger because
it's just not going to get used enough
to actually you know see a return on
your investment has to be so that's the
gap there really I wanted to look at it
purely from the AV driver perspective
where do they need to add range to their
vehicle where are the places they want
to go governments in the major auto
markets of Europe Japan and the US are
all pushing car companies to sell more
EVs
by setting stricter auto emissions
limits and incentivizing drivers to buy
them but perhaps nowhere in the world is
there a bigger focus on EVs
than in China the Chinese government is
aggressively promoting the technology
setting ambitious sales targets and
regulating automakers to build more
electric vehicles it's also helping to
subsidize the expansion of the charging
network here in Shanghai I've taken
delivery of this in Shanghai James arity
felt this investment and had a smoother
test than most of us I've lived in
Shanghai more than a dozen years going
on two decades and driving is immensely
stressful you have 20 million people
packed into roads which were designed in
many cases for horses a huge advantage
to the evie business in China is the
fact that the state is involved the
government
involved you don't have to wait around
for private companies to do all of the
work
this is China state grid it's one of the
largest state-owned enterprises and they
set up these evie stations all over the
country James spoke to auto industry
analyst Bill Russo about China's
approach to electric vehicles so what
can you tell us about the the evie
market in China what makes it different
from say the US market what's different
is in China they've made it a national
agenda to repower transportation so
China could take leadership in in evey
but they're not going to in a
traditional gasoline-powered exactly
it's playing a decades-long game of
catch-up there is not a single electric
vehicle company in China that has had to
build a supercharger network for its
cars all of that investment in evey
charging infrastructure is coming from
public and private investments outside
of the automotive industry heck did
Henry Ford have to build the gasoline
fueling infrastructure for the United
States no Standard Oil helped with that
so it has it been successful do you
think the electrification of the
industry half of the total sales of
electric vehicles in the world are now
sold here in China so absolutely it's
gotten off the ground now can it achieve
you know escape velocity to where it's
competing head-to-head with the internal
combustion engine I think that's going
to take several years around the world
governments and automakers are
emphasizing electric vehicles German car
makers are making some of the biggest
investments and Germany has made v's a
policy priority as part of their aim to
be carbon neutral by 2050 so here we're
passing through a small wind farm so
they're aggressively regulating their
auto manufacturers and subsidizing the
purchase of EVs
but they're betting on a technology that
is still new and strange to most drivers
when I was much younger I had a car that
I could fix myself I could do engine
tune-ups the brakes I could change all
the parts but I've never seen anything
like this this is
completely different this is not your
father's Mercedes in places like Germany
the government and automakers want more
EVs on the road and soon but the push
hasn't yet translated into a better
experience for drivers I pull into a gas
station and you think this would be a
nice place to put a electric charger
right but of course there are none here
and this is a fundamental problem they
call it the chicken and egg problem
right how are you gonna have enough
electric cars on the road if you can't
charge them why should I put electric
charges up if there aren't so many
electric cars on the road someone's got
to solve that problem while this
technology has improved since the first
electric vehicle hit the road more than
two decades ago a lot of big challenges
remain and that includes your range
where you can plug in and the base cost
of these vehicles which is pretty
expensive
our reporters found that when it comes
to their daily routines they could make
these cars work I'm running out to pick
up some Krispy Kreme donuts for my son's
tenth birthday it's just it just strikes
me as a perfect type of errand to run in
this car once I got used to the charging
rhythm and when there were adequate
charging opportunities it was a minor
inconvenience it meant planning ahead
but it's certainly doable I was vaguely
aware that he was quite popular in China
I was surprised at how much easier it
was to use it to plug it in and I
expected but breaking out of those
routines and taking these cars the
distance involved anxiety and compromise
within 24 hours was telling people that
I wish that I had bought an electric
vehicle and whenever I leased my last
car but since then I have to say I've
had a bit of a change of heart the Vegas
trip was pretty traumatizing because of
the challenges of finding a charger
charging us this takes forever there's
just not enough of it and the places
where you
- drive - at this point though I would
want to have a second vehicle a
conventional one for longer trips more
models of electric vehicles are on the
way and car companies say the technology
and infrastructure will improve
automakers are wagering billions that
the future is electric but is it enough
one thing's for sure their plans will be
tested on the long road ahead
[Music]
you
[Music]